Yeah.
In this video we'll see an alternative for visualizing a undirected graphical
models like the conditional random fields known as the factor graph.
Okay.
We've seen in the previous video that one way of visualizing and conditional
random fields is to uh,
draw a network where each node would curse spawn to one of the random variables
in the model.
And then we would draw an edge between each node that share at least one factor
in the product of factors,
a form of the conditional random fields.
Yeah.
Now,
one problem with this visualization is that it's actually ambiguous.
So we notice a,
for instance,
that we actually have a clique between,
there's a mistake here.
This would be x two.
We actually have a clique between y one y two x two.
So I have a quick like this here,
that is a subset of the graph where each note,
uh,
each pair of node is connected to each other.
Uh,
and this actually kind of suggests that perhaps there was a factor that had as
its three arguments y one y two x two because in this case that I have to draw
an edge between y one y two and the edge between y one and x two and another
edge between y two x two.
But in fact,
in my actual model,
all I had was three factors.
One between [inaudible] and [inaudible] and other one between y to annex two and
another one between y one x two.
And,
uh,
you know,
in some sense it's as if I had just a single factor,
uh,
which was the product.
So a single factor between y one y two x two where,
uh,
which was the product of my simpler factor y one and y two times the factor of
between y to annex two times the factor between y one and x two.
But what if I had a model with actually had the factor between these three
random variables that was more complicated.
Uh,
it's actually their,
would they sort of correspond to different models?
A one which is a bit more complicated and can model more,
uh,
sophisticated and interactions between these three random variables.
And the other one would just assumes that,
you know,
the way I'm going to model preferences between the values of these three random
variables is as a product of preferences between pairs of variables.
And so what we'll see is that there's another type of graph dealers
digitalization,
which is going to allow us to distinguish between these two cases.
So this visualization is known as a factor graph.
And the idea is that we're actually going to add nodes in our graph that
corresponds to the factors.
So in our conditional random fields,
which is a linear chain that has a context window of radius one,
this workers respond to that at this factor graph.
So,
uh,
usually factors,
we illustrate them as a little square like this.
And not each square corresponds to,
we factor in my,
uh,
product of factors form of my conditional random fields.
And now each factor note is going to be connected to its argument to the random
variables that are,
uh,
correspond to arguments of the factor.
So,
for instance,
we have this factor here and it's connected to why three and x three.
Uh,
because in the factor,
which is this,
uh,
it depends on x three and it depends on why three.
Similarly,
I'm going to have this factor here and it's going to be connected to x two and
y,
sorry,
x two and y three because again,
it's a factor that depends on next twin wire three and so on,
say for this factor.
And also had to have a pairwise factor here,
uh,
which is here,
which is connected to why three and why four because it expresses a preference
over the joint value of y three and why for now,
the reason why this is less ambiguous is uh,
because now we explicitly have the factors illustrated in our visualization.
So consider this very simple example where I have this mark of network,
uh,
was corresponds to three variables,
each connected to each other like we've discussed before.
Well in this case,
we don't really know whether it's uh,
it's actually a model where we have three factors that are over pairs or just a
single factor over three variables.
Uh,
however,
given this factor graph,
well,
if I was to draw to infer what is the mark of network visualization based on
that factor graph?
Well,
I'd have to,
uh,
draw an edge between this node and this node because there is this factor that
connects them.
So this,
there's one factor that involves the two of them.
Same thing because of diff that this factor,
I need to draw an edge in the MAC mark of network viz between these two
variables.
And similarly for that factor,
I'd get an edge here and we see that also this factor graph with a single factor
was actually correspond to a the same mark of network.
So while going from factor graph to mark of network is well defined,
inferring from a mark of network,
what is the factor graph is actually ambiguous.
So that's not a well-defined operation.
So we've lost less than formation by drawing.
So,
or we're providing more information by drawing the factor graph as opposed to
drawing the mark of network.
There's still some advantages in that mock up network.
It's kind of more intuitive and easier to infer the conditional independence's
like we've done before.
Though we could extend that logic to a fact factor graphs.
But in all cases,
uh,
when the information about the factories is not as much important and we're more
concerned about showing the independence's or dependencies between the variable
often will favor drawing and mark of network.
But if the actual information about the factors is important,
then we'll want to use a factor graph.
All right,
so this covers,
uh,
the,
the second type of visualization for undirected graphical model known as the
fact that graph.